a man who has been covering sports
expertly writing books on it for decades
arm and Catan here on the Rich Eisen
show - well I feel like I'm gonna have
to come to the defense of Dave Barrett
here okay pretty quickly okay explain
who Dave Barrett is Armen explain your
role in all of this
please Dave Barrett is the
singer-songwriter from the original one
shining moment he owns the song and all
the Masters and everything into it it's
I think it was 32 years last night a
long time ago when I was a writer
reporter at Sports Illustrated David and
I grew up in the same hometown of
Bloomfield Hills Michigan he was at the
rival high school and over hi I was at
laaser high school which was named after
a road not not the greatest thing you
could ever happen for a high school but
we we competed against each other and in
sports day was a really good basketball
player went on to play college at Albion
or a basketball on scholarship in Albion
College so I don't mean to stop you
right there Armen are you telling me
that he's had his own one shining moment
on the basketball so you had many he had
many one shining moment particularly
against loss or high school when Andover
would beat us like a drum at times but
he you know he's had a very long loving
history with with basketball and um so I
goes and Dave was up at East Lansing at
Michigan State in a in a bar trying to
talk to this girl when Larry Bird Magic
Johnson were on television and failed
miserably in the conversation at the bar
and started to write some lyrics down
turned out to be the beginning of and
really one shining moment came out in
this day described it as sort of a one
big woosh but we were good friends and
he would come to New York and visit and
at one time he came and stayed in our
apartment and all 482 square feet of it
and slept on the couch and he goes hey
I've got this song I think it's pretty
good and it's a college basketball song
and I said okay and as it turned out I
just knew
some friends over at CBS sports that
they were looking for a theme song for
college basketball for the Final Four
and March Madness and so I said I
listened to it and at the time it had
this incredible piano Prelude which in
the early versions of one shining moment
actually made air but I took it over to
CBS a friend of mine over there named
Bob Tasi mm-hmm who was in the marketing
department and as the story goes you
know it's literally a cassette tape and
as the story goes he played it in his
office and people were coming in from
other offices to listen to it and Bob
said you know he called me up and he
goes I think we found our song I was
like wow so I called Dave and David was
then involved in doing a lot of singing
songwriting songwriting all over the
country and then it kind of got its way
into into CBS sports and you know we're
supposed to as the story goes supposed
to be the closing theme song for a Super
Bowl but the game ran long and it ended
up being you know the signature songs
probably right now in sports despite mr.
curmudgeon here armen I'm not I'm not
I'm not alone in this and I don't mean
it cuz again I know he's a good friend
of yours so I don't mean to denigrate I
just I'm just giving my my two cents on
this so just hearing hearing the story
you're saying one shining moment the
initial writing of it was born out of
one failing moment trying to hit on a
woman at a bars what you're saying
Armin that's pretty much that's what I'm
just trying to I'm just trying to really
moment in a bar okay one Heisman moment
gave birth to one light shining moment
and then and then you passed it along
and it and and it's now blossomed into
something so does he get does your buddy
get like rigid like a residual check
big fat residual check every real oh no
what I think no I think actually he has
a an agreement that has rolled over you
know in various numbers of years for the
last 32 years Bobby Bonilla it's been
quite a little annuity in terms of you
know you don't have to create too many
one shining moments to pay for college
education and things of that nature but
you know David is a he's a very
accomplished singer songwriter as well I
mean toured with Art Garfunkel he's won
Emmys for you know his theme songs for
PBS specials and he actually wrote a
number of other themes for CBS Sports
and including the PGA and things like
that so it's not a kind of a you know a
one-and-done sort of thing for Dave does
the master seem his no that would be too
much rich you're gonna get the final
four oh I think he probably wrote a
theme for the Masters but I don't think
it's I don't think it's his because if
it was I I think I would know about okay
I just I just figured that look I'm
saying is that what was good in 1987
doesn't really speak it doesn't resonate
in the sports world for me in 2019
that's that's all I gotta tell you I did
seven Final Fours I was on the floor as
a sideline reporter for seven of those
babies and I mean I sat next door stood
next to Tom Izzo and and Mateen Cleaves
when they had tears in their eyes as
that was playing inside the arena I
stood next to Mike's Chesky and his this
team when they won it's an emotional
moment and it's something that is used
as a device to motivate teams and you
know I don't know how many things I it's
hard to say how many things at last it's
32 years true in our business let alone
32 seconds sometimes well you have you
have I have yeah I'm kind of going on 35
at this point in time yeah so I'm I
don't know if you know this I'm I'm a
new guy at the Athletics for the video
Thanks we're launching April 29th I'm
the anchor and one of three executive
producers and we're going to deplane
this off okay you know Monday April 29
yeah that's one that's one that's one
Armand moment what do you think I'm just
I'm pretty excited about it no no I'm
just saying that that might be your name
if you need a name for a show one arm
and moment and you can have your buddy
right the right the open for your show I
think that I think that ship has sailed
[Laughter]
you know I'm a storyteller you are that
sir all right so uh III would be remiss
to not before I let you go what do you
what do you think of Tigers chances this
week Armin well if we if anything looks
like what he's been playing like in the
last you know week or so he's playing
lights out I think you know look big
moments he's made for these things and
if he gets anywhere near the hunt on
Saturday or Sunday I think the world is
going to see the kind of tiger that we
saw in the early 2000s I think he's
still got enough game but Kenny pot I
mean that'll be the big thing could he
put one of the pressures on and all that
stuff but I mean the story itself is you
know given where he was you know two
years ago to where he is today or even a
year ago last May in eighteen to
nineteen it's hard to believe he is
where he is now and I think it's one of
the great comebacks in the history of
sport and you know I say that from a
perspective of spending three years of
my life writing a book about him with so
yep I'm rooting for him for sure yeah
you literally wrote the book Tiger Woods
with Jeff Benedict and it is you know I
lost track of the number of people who
thought he would never make it back to
win anything let alone contend in a
masters or any major championship like
he's been doing over the last several
months well when we were in the throes
of finishing the book this was early
2017 or 2018 excuse me and it you know
things looked really really bleak and
you know for him to come back and show
signs that he was going to you know he
had some old form coming back and he was
just happier he was a for the first time
in a long time and I saw Natori and for
like the third or fourth time in that
very short period of time he looked he
look happier
he was more engaging it was more human
than I had ever seen him in the in the
three years of really being a tiger
ologist at that point in time and I
think now with his health and you know
his outlook on life he's in as good of
places he's ever been and and frankly I
think he deserves that he's lived at
least two lifetimes that I can count and
probably someone more in their other
areas so you know if he stays healthy
and he's in the hunt as I said it's
going to be an unbelievable amount of
people coming to TV and we saw it at the
Tour Championship on that 18th fairway
and walking up to that green and it
reminded me of back in the in the 1997
when he won the British and and then
again in 97 when he won the Western open
it looked like Moses and the Red Sea so
you know I'm I'll be watching and and
you know I think he's I think he's got a
shot I don't think he's got a great shot
but you know I think if things turn out
the you know and he can putt he'll be in
it armen thanks for the call appreciate
it
you bet send my best to your
singer-songwriter front it's a my best
it's on army Kitaen for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on be our live or
download the Rich Eisen show app